وفيما يتعلق بملابسات هذا الاغتيال كما
نعلمه بالطائرات الاسرائيليه لكن هؤلاء
القاده لم يكونوا مختبئين يعني كانوا في
وسط في بيوتهم مع عائلاتهم ولم يكونوا
متخفين حتى يمكن للاحتلال ان يزعم انه
اصطاده
هو مع الاسف هناك حديث احاديث كثيره
وروايات كثيره
وربما يعني
روايات اكثر من طرف تحدث عنها بان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ربما غرر بهم
وبالتالي دفعهم الى التراخي في اجراء
سلسله الاجراءات الامنيه المشدده هناك
روايه تحدثت عن ان هذا الوفد سوف كان من
المقرر ان يذهب جل هؤلاء القاده الذين
اغتيلوا اليوم في اطار وفد لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي كان سيتوجه الى العاصمه المصريه
القاهره بعد دعوه من السلطات المصريه
لاستكمال المشاورات حول طبيعه التهدئه
التي توصلت اليها الوسيط المصري والوسيط
الاممي والوسيط القطري وكل الوسطاء عقب
اغتيال واستشهاد خضر عدنان في سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكان يوم استشهاد خضر
عدنان كان هذا الوفد من المقرر ان يذهب
ايضا الى العاصمه المصريه لاجراء مزيد من
المشاورات وايضا لعقد اول الاجتماع رسمي
لاعضاء المكتب السياسي المنتخبين في ضوء
الانتخابات الاخيره التي انتهت التي
اجرتها حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ويومها تم
تاجيل هذه الزياره اليوم هناك حديث من ان
اعضاء الوفد الذين اغتيلوا وايضا اخرين
كان من المقرر ايضا ان يسافر الى العاصمه
المصريه لاجراء المحادثات حول اتفاق
التهدئه التي تم التوصل اليه في الاسبوع
الماضي واين ايضا استكمال رحلتهم لعقد
اجتماعات الاجتماعات الاولى للاعضاء
المكتب السياسي المنتخبين في كل الساحات
في لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ولكن ربما هذا
كان واحد من دواعي التراخي في اللجوء الى
الاجراءات الامنيه المشدده وبالتالي عادوا
ربما الى اماكن سكناهم
لربما توديع ذويهم او ما شابه ذلك قبيله
مغادره قطاع غزه لهذه الرحله ايا كانت
يعني الدواعي والمبررات ولكن بالتاكيد في
قطاع غزه وسائل التخفي والتمويه
والاجراءات هي في نهايه المطاف ليست كبيره
ليست كبيره على اعتبار انه قطع رقعه
جغرافيه صغيره هي عباره عن سهل وكتل
اسمنتيه في نهايه المطاف معظم الاجراءات
تتخذ في اطار هذه الكتل الاسمنتيه بمعنى
البنايات السكنيه وليس هناك تضاريس وعره
وجبال شاهقه ووديان وما شابه ذلك حتى يتم
التحسن من قبل هؤلاء المقاومين في اطارها
او في جوفها وبالتالي تبقى الاجراءات
الامنيه بما هو متوفر ومعروف ومتعارف عليه
في قطاع باللجوء بتغيير اماكن سكناهم بعدم
التحرك باغلاق الموبايلات بعدم الظهور
بشكل علني والتنقل بشكل كبير هذه هي
الاجراءات الاساسيه التي يعمد الى اتخاذها
من قبل المقاومين الفلسطينيين او من قبل
المطلوبين وعناصر المقاومه بشكل عام في
قطاع غزه في حال التوترات لكن ان نتحدث عن
تحصينات شديده وتحصينات في باطن الارض
كبيره ومشاكل ذلك هذه ليست متوفره وان
كانت متوفره هي متوفره على نطاق ضيق وليست
بحوزه كل المقاومين الفلسطينيين ولذلك
ربما يبدو الامر اكثر سهوله من وجهه نظر
من هم خارج قطاع غزه فيما يتعلق بها وهو
ربما سؤال عريض لكثير من المشاهدين الذين
يتابعون مثل هذه الاجراءات السؤال البسيط
كيف يتم الوصول الى هذه الى المقاومين من
هذا الطراز ومنها ومثل الاسماء والاجابه
كما استعرضناها قبل قليل ولذلك هذا
الاغتيال كان مقررا له ان يحقق عده اهداف
لاسرائيل وان تجبي هي اثمان باهظه من
الجهاد الاسلامي ومن ذراعه العسكريه في
حين اسرائيل لا تدفع كثير من الاثمان
وتعيد التناقضات الى الساحه الفلسطينيه
وتخلط الاوراق من جديد ومن ثم تعمد الى
جوله ربما جوله تصعيد يوم او يومين تتدخل
الوسطاء ومن ثم التوصل الى تفاهمات لاطلاق
نار كما جرى في كل موجات التصعيد السابقه
في نهايه المطاف وتعود وتبدو الامور وكان
اسرائيل هي يعني يعني جعلت الجهاد
الاسلامي يدفع ثمنا باهظا ومن ثم عادت الى
وقف اطلاق النار حتى وان كان هناك رشقات
صاروخيه وتجاوزت منطقه الغلاف هكذا يبدو
ان اسرائيل كانت تريد هذا السيناريو لكن
مما جرى حتى الان بعد تقريبا نحو اكثر من
12 ساعه من الان تقريبا يبدو وكان الفصائل
الفلسطينيه قرات المشهد بشكل جيد ولذلك
ردت عليه بالرد المناسب وربما بذات
التفكير بمعنى ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
اساسا لم تصدر كثير من البيانات لم تتحدث
بكثير من التفصيلات داخل بياناتها
وتصريحاتها لم تتحدث عن الردود وطبيعه
الرد ومدى الرد ونوعيه الرد وبالتالي كل
هذا ظل محل تساؤلات ربما اربك صانع القرار
الاسرائيلي وهو ليس يربكه فقط على الاقل
سوف يستنزفه ان استمر لساعات او لايام سوف
يستنزف الجيش الاسرائيلي ويستنزف الشارع
الاسرائيلي الغير معتاد اساسا على هذا
النحو الحياه ان يكون مع احابيثا ومسجونا
ومحاصرا ومقيدا في تحركاته ولا يوجد عمل
وكل هذه الاشياء الذي ربما الشارع
الفلسطيني اكثر قدره على تحملها نظرا لطول
الحصار المفروض وطول الويلات التي صبت على
راسه في قطاع غزه وفي الاراضي الفلسطينيه
بشكل عام الاغتيالات يعني ليست شيئا جديدا
سياسه تنفذه اسرائيل منذ مده طويله تستعين
فيها بعيون على الارض
وعيون في السماء
العيون في السماء كثيره لكن فلسطينيه هل
يعني في مثل هذه الحالات حالات الاغتيال
التي حدثت بالامس او فجر اليوم هل
يفتح ايضا تحقيقات
حول من ارشد على من ام ان الامر لم يكن
يحتاج الى مرشدين لانه هم في حاله هدنه
وليسوا في حاله عسكريه حتى يتخفوا
ويغيبوا عن اعين الاحتلال
لا بالتاكيد بالتاكيد عقب كل عمليه اغتيال
او انفجار او اي حدث امني في قطاع غزه
بالتاكيد جهات الاختصاص في القطاع سواء
كانت من داخل الفصيل المعني بهذه الاحداث
او الجهات الاختصاص في قطاع غزه بشكل عام
وزاره الداخليه والاجهزه الامنيه وغيرها
بالتاكيد تقف على تفاصيل هذه الاحداث
وتجري تحقيقا وتفتح ملفات وتستجوب اناس
حتى تقف على الثغرات التي ترشدهم على
كيفيه الوصول لمثل هذه الاسماء الكبيره
والوازنه في صفوف الاذرع العسكريه من
مختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وبالتاكيد عقب كل حادثه اغتيال يستفاد
يستخلص العبر والدروس وتعطى تعليمات
ميدانيه لنشطاء الفصائل الفلسطينيه
لاتخاذها حتى لا يكون صيدا سهلا ونحن
نتحدث عن سهوله الوصول لاننا فقط ربما
اوقفنا الزمن
عدسه الكاميرا عند هذه اللحظه التي تم
اصطيادهم واغتيالهم فيها ولكن نحن نتحدث
عن اكثر من اسبوع عشره ايام من الرصد
والمتابعه والتحري وجمع المعلومات في هذا
المكان الضيق وكما قلنا السهل وغير المحصن
وما شابه ذلك عشرات من الطائرات
الاسرائيليه في السماء وبالتاكيد هناك من
يتعاون معهم على الارض ولكن كما قلنا هذا
هذه المتابعه الحثيثه لحظه بلحظه ويوم
بيوم وساعه بساعه بالتاكيد هي نتائج جهد
جهود مضنيه بالتاكيد سوف يحصلون على طرف
خيط ومعلومه ربما ترشدهم الى مكان ربما
الى اماكن ومن ثم حصرها يعني ربما معالجات
كثيره حتى يصل الى هذه الى هذه ما ليس
الامر كما يبدو سهلا كما يبدو للحظه
الاولى وللوهله الاولى لكن اذا اغمى
قررناه بتضاريس وعره وساحات واسعه جدا
وكبيره ومتراميه الاطراف في مناطق اخرى
بالتاكيد يبدو اسهل من ذي قبل على الرغم
من اننا في زمن
التقنيات الحديثه وامكانيات التصوير
اللامتناهيه من حيث الدقه ربما سهلت كل
شيء ونحن نشاهد الصور التي ربما ترسل من
مناطق اخرى في الحروب كحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وغيرها من المناطق نرى الفعل
الرئيسي والكبير لهذه التقنيات وامكانيات
التصوير ومن ثم اتخاذ القرارات في الميدان
واريد دحدوح بن غزه شكرا